en este vídeo quiero seguir platicando
acerca del consumo y de inversión el
objetivo principal de estos vídeos es
que tú mismo puedas pensar en algunos
gastos y ver si estás consumiendo o si
estás invirtiendo como platicábamos en
el vídeo pasado una inversión es gastar
dinero pero de forma tal que traiga un
bienestar colectivo que ayude a mejorar
la riqueza de la sociedad y que ayude
económicamente a todos por otro lado un
consumo es un dinero que se gasta pero
únicamente con fines personales o sea
ayuda a mejorar tu estatus social o
aumentar tu ego o hacerte más orgulloso
más feliz pero realmente no es algo que
trae un beneficio para todos
entonces ya había ya habíamos visto
algunos ejemplos en el vídeo pasado y
ahorita quiero pensar en otros casos
porque son interesantes entonces
pensemos en irse de vacaciones va hay
varias formas de irse de vacaciones pero
quiero empezar con una vacación sencilla
entonces aquí le voy a poner vacación
canción
sencilla sencilla va entonces la idea es
que te vas de vacaciones con tu familia
a un lugar muy tranquilito no se te vas
a acampar a la marquesa y te la pasas
muy bien la cosa es que sea algo
relajante va entonces de entrada estoy
aquí es un consumo o es una inversión
pues al parecer así visto desde lejos
esto podría parecer un consumo verdad es
tiempo libre te estás tomando un tiempo
libre no estás yendo a trabajar tus
hijos no están yendo a la escuela y
entonces tiene toda la pinta de ser un
consumo de apps no sé no apuesto cuánto
cuesta pero digamos que te gastas 20 mil
pesos 20 mil pesos te vas una semana a
la marqueza y te gastas 20 mil pesos
acampando y pues en los gastos de la
tienda de campaña y todo eso bueno
entonces parece ser un consumo verdad
parece ser un consumo porque dejas de
trabajar dejas de ser productivo sin
embargo hay un contra argumento para
esto mira irse de vacaciones a una
vacación sencilla y relajante le voy a
poner aquí que es relajante
relajante tiene sus ventajas tiene sus
ventajas a lo mejor esta vacación te
ayuda a concentrarte más te ayuda a
restablecer tus prioridades en la vida a
definir un objetivo más claro puedes
descansar puedes pensar pues más
tranquilamente porque ya pasaste tiempo
de calidad con tu familia y entonces
esto te ayuda a colaborar más con la
sociedad te ayuda a hacer una persona
más productiva ya crear más valor para
todos a lo mejor de hecho si no te
hubieras ido de vacaciones puede ser que
eventualmente te hago test que te artes
de trabajar y que pues ya la verdad no
puedas colaborar con nada entonces visto
desde ese punto de vista esto de aquí es
una inversión lo voy a pintar con el
color verde de las inversiones ya está
su cuadrado de inversión va y entonces
bueno es una inversión o bueno podría
hacer una inversión siempre y cuando la
aproveches para relajarte y para mejorar
pero déjame comparar está esta vacación
sencilla de acá con una vacación
extravagante si le voy a poner por aquí
vacación vacación extravagante
extravagante variante entonces no sé a
lo mejor te quieres ir al río nilo y en
el río nilo hay una persona que rema y
rema y te pasea por todo el río nilo y
luego van y te sientas en un gran trono
y hay muchos nativos que bailan para ti
y te dejan usar joyería de oro y el
chiste es que tú y tu familia se sientan
como todos unos reyes va entonces esta
es una vacación extravagante y uno puede
argumentar que si a lo mejor tú
descansas dejas de trabajar de hecho
pero bueno más bien yo diría que es al
revés como es extravagante puede ser que
acabes un poco más estresado y que de
hecho haya un cierto efecto en tu ego
que sea negativo que te creas mucho y
entonces a lo mejor no no es buena idea
pero bueno incluso aunque sea relajante
hay un pequeño
únicamente un pequeño valor que se está
invirtiendo en esa relajación digamos si
esta vacación extravagante cuesta 200
mil pesos por decir algo porque gastarte
mucho en irte hasta áfrica y en todo
este oro que te están permitiendo usar y
lo que sea entonces de estos 200 mil
pesos únicamente 20 mil pesos es lo que
estás invirtiendo en relajarte entonces
podemos pensar que de aquí 20 mil pesos
20 mil pesos son una inversión le voy a
poner así son una inversión en el color
verde de las inversiones pero lo
restante nosotros cuánto sería 20.000
menos perdón 200.000 menos 20 mil 180
mil
180.000 los otros 180 mil pesos pues
únicamente los estás utilizando pues
para gratificar a tu ego para sentirte
mejor y realmente no están generando una
mayor productividad de nada bien y en la
sociedad entonces esto de acá sería con
su me voy a poner con su
consumo vale entonces bueno o sea fíjate
la gran diferencia verdad que es una
vacación relajante que realmente te
ayuda a ser más productivo y sólo una
pequeña parte de esta vacación
extravagante también te ayuda a ser
productivo y el resto es consumo claro
estos 200 mil pesos se los está
transfiriendo a los nativos no se están
perdiendo realmente pues no es tan malo
verdad porque se los das a los nativos
formativos lo pueden gastar en su aldea
y a lo mejor que puedes pues tener una
mejor economía pero esta acción el hecho
de pagar los 200.000 por sí mismo su
objetivo no es generar riqueza esta
transacción en específico pues no está
haciendo que crezca el pastel para todos
claro o sea no es mala idea estás
cambiando gratificación personal o sea
tú eres una persona que está dando 200
mil pesos a cambio de que gratifiquen a
tu ego entonces no no es tan grave
porque de todas formas sigue siendo un
cambio verdad desde riquezas de cierta
forma pero no está creando valor y por
tanto lo clasificó como consumo déjame
pasar a un ejemplo similar una bolsa una
bolsa una bolsa así para para mujer
supongamos que mi esposa va a la tienda
se va al walmart y compra una bolsa de
200 pesos de 200 pesos entonces esto es
un consumo o inversión pues yo digo que
es una inversión es una bolsa barata es
una bolsa nada más de 200 pesos y esta
bolsa puede ayudarle a mi esposa pues no
seas a ser más organizada a trabajar
mejor a lo mejor necesita una bolsa para
ir a trabajar para que realmente la
contraten no sé bueno el chiste es que
esta bolsa realmente está creando un
bien y está haciendo que una persona se
vuelva más productiva entonces una bolsa
del wal mart de 200 pesos si es una
inversión es una inversión sin embargo
si tenemos una una bolsa no sea alguna
marca fina ligamos louis vuitton vamos a
pensar que ahora compramos una marca
louis no sé si se escribe así creo que
si una bolsa louis vuitton que puede ser
carísima y puede costar como como estaba
pues vamos a ponerle 2000 pesos van
entonces una bolsa louis vuitton pues
incluso más 20 mil pesos podría costar
20 mil pesos pero fíjate o sea sigue
siendo un gasto sigue siendo una bolsa
que sigue ayudando a organizar pero
solamente una pequeña parte de eso
quizás nada más estos 200 pesos son una
inversión 200 pesos pero el resto todo
lo demás los otros china aquí es un
montón verdad que sería 19 mil 19 mil
800 pesos son un gasto que no está
invirtiendo en nada entonces esto sería
un consumo no está generando ningún bien
para la sociedad entonces esto como lo
podemos pensar esto lo podemos pensar
pues simplemente como un intercambio del
ego del ego con louis vuitton con louis
vuitton vino o sea con los visto en la
compañía y no la persona entonces
básicamente estás dándole bueno les
estás dando dos 200 pesos que si es como
como de inversión que si te hace una
persona productiva pero además le estás
dando 19 mil 800 pesos extra nada más
por una gratificación y lo que recibe
esta cambio es es gratificación le voy a
poner aquí
gratificación y cada acción ahora la
pregunta es esto es bueno o es malo para
la sociedad pues yo digo que al menos
hasta aquí es neutral o sea esto no le
está haciendo un gran bienestar a la
sociedad pero tampoco está haciendo que
x se destruyó o sea que se destruya
riqueza ni nada por el estilo de hecho a
lo mejor podría ser bueno a lo mejor
estos 19 mil 800 pesos pues parte de eso
se va al material de la bolsa verdad que
a lo mejor son como 100 pesos pero todo
el resto ahora los tiene louis vuitton y
louis vuitton la compañía ahora sí nos
puede invertir se los puede dar a su
amigo del capitalista de riesgo y a lo
mejor el capitalista de riesgo lo
invierte en nuevas tecnologías solares
entonces esto de acá estos diecinueve
mil ochocientos bueno más o menos pero
estos diecinueve mil 800 se pueden ir
realmente a energía solar por ejemplo
la energía solar solar y entonces éstos
no se destruyeron y si al final de
cuentas cayeron en una inversión sin
embargo esta transacción en la cual tú
compras la bolsa y recibes gratificación
es consumo claro donde si se gasta o
donde si se destruye un poco de riqueza
es en todo lo que invierte louis vuitton
en mercadotecnia en convencerte que
realmente necesitas una vuelta pero
bueno no es tan grave puede ser que
parte de esos y se invierta en energía
solar y a fin de cuentas esto sólo es
una transacción de consumo entre una
persona pues que está más o menos
insegura y una empresa que sabe cómo
vender y a las personas inseguras bueno
ya no es tan grave sin embargo hay un
caso más extremo donde realmente todo
está muy muy mal déjame pasarme tantito
para cada entonces este caso sería el
siguiente entonces imagínate que este de
aquí eres tú estoy aquí eres tú te voy a
poner una carita feliz y tienes una
corona y gastas pues vamos a pensar qué
gastas 200 mil pesos bueno le voy a
poner 300 mil para que ya no tengamos
tantos 12 casas 300 mil pesos con él un
único objetivo de que haya 200 personas
200 personas son las que te hagan sentir
bien no sé a lo mejor hacen bailes
graciosos para ti y te alaban y te están
consintiendo y digamos que por una hora
por una hora esas personas únicamente
tienen toda su atención dedicada a ti
entonces qué sucede con esta transacción
yo digo que esto de aquí es la forma más
pura de consumo y que no solo pues no
sólo es consumo sino que derecho
destruye riqueza en la sociedad porque
pues o sea si obviamente está
transfiriendo estos 300 mil pesos a
estas 200 personas no sé muy bien cuánto
le toca a cada una
creo que como como 1500 pesos bueno no
sé si tú haciendo las cuentas bien pero
aunque les esté transfiriendo riqueza y
ese dinero no se esté perdiendo digamos
esos billetes llegan en las manos de
alguien más pues lo que está sucediendo
es que ahora estas 200 personas todo su
tiempo toda su capacidad productiva la
están usando en algo que no es realmente
productivo únicamente están bueno están
bailando para ti y te están no sé
adorando y alabando y lo que sea
no están utilizando su tiempo para
producir más a lo mejor pudieran no se
están enseñándole a sus hijos a leer o
podrían estar creando trabajos teniendo
buenas ideas entonces realmente
realmente este es un ejemplo de consumo
así muy muy grave o bueno muy muy puro
esto es consumo totalmente pero aquí si
se destruye riqueza destruye riqueza en
el sentido se está destruyendo riqueza
en el sentido de que el tiempo de estas
personas no se está aprovechando para
generar riqueza para tener más manzanas
para tener un mayor bienestar en el
mundo en términos así técnicos lo que
está sucediendo aquí es que la cantidad
de dinero se mantiene fija y el dinero
nada más se transfirió sin embargo
comparativamente con que estas personas
estén trabajando se está perdiendo
riqueza se está perdiendo bienes que
podría tener la sociedad porque se está
perdiendo la capacidad productiva de
estas personas entonces qué sucede
tienen la misma cantidad de dinero pero
una menor cantidad de bienes
comparativamente y esto al final de
cuentas lo que hace es que aumenten los
precios y pues en términos técnicos que
se genere inflación eso es malo para
todos y bueno no es buena idea ser
consumo de este estilo bueno ahorita ya
ya se me acabó el tiempo pero lo que sí
quiero que hagas es seguir pensando en
estas ideas pensar en algunos tipos de
gastos y pensar si eso de ahí es un
consumo o bien si es una inversión que
si están generando riqueza para la
sociedad o no en los siguientes vídeos
te voy a platicar un poco acerca de cómo
el gobierno pues realmente hace algunas
cosas en específico algunas acciones
para motivar a la gente a que consuma o
bien a que inviertan porque dependiendo
del tiempo puede ser que sea buena idea
una cosa o la otra pero bueno nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo y le voy a dejar
hasta aquí